Why is gender even a thing?
We’ve talked about what gender is, and how
it affects people’s lives.
But we’ve skipped over a fundamental part
of the whole issue of gender:
Why does it matter to us so much?
Gender isn’t the same in all cultures.
Mainstream Western ideas have focused on the
idea of gender as a binary, with masculinity and
femininity serving as mutual opposites.
But other cultures have three genders, or
see gender as fluid, or describe gender as a
spectrum rather than a set of distinct types.
For example, many Native American and First
Nation peoples recognize a third gender that
incorporates both the masculine and feminine, and
it plays a specific, sacred role within their culture.
While different tribes all have different
terms for this gender within their own languages,
nowadays many use the umbrella term Two Spirit.
But there are no known societies that have
no concept of gender.
So, why is that?
Why do we, no matter what society we live
in, ascribe so much meaning to gender?
[Theme Music]
To talk about why we have gender in the first
place, we need to go back to the three theories
that sociology is built on:
structural functional theory, symbolic
interaction theory, and social conflict theory.
All three of these theories have different
perspectives on why gender exists.
Let’s start with structural functionalism.
Remember, the structural functional approach
understands human behavior as part of systems that
help keep society organized and functioning.
From this perspective, gender is a means
of organizing society into distinct roles that
complement each other.
Some anthropologists have argued that
hunter-gatherer societies originated the idea that
men are providers and women take care of the home.
Men were physically stronger and didn’t
have the demands of childbearing,
which made it easier for them to take on more
aggressive, autonomous roles, like hunting or warfare.
And these roles became institutionalized.
Even once physical strength was no longer
important for many jobs, it was taken for granted
that men would be the breadwinners and women
would care for the children.
But there are holes in this theory –
namely that the early anthropologists who
studied this dynamic overemphasized the role
of things like big game hunting.
More recent anthropological work suggests
that gathering, fishing, and small game hunting
– all of which were also performed by women
– played a much larger role in providing food
in these societies.
But the idea that we have two genders to play
complementary roles has stuck around, partially
through the work of sociologist Talcott Parsons.
He argued that boys and girls are socialized to take
on traits that are complementary to each other, to make
it easier to maintain stable, productive family units.
Boys are taught what Parsons calls instrumental
qualities, such as confidence and competitiveness,
that prepare them for the labor force.
Meanwhile, girls are taught expressive qualities,
such as empathy and sensitivity, which prepare
them to care for their families.
Parsons’ theory was that a successful family
needs people to have complementary skill sets, and
gender gives us a way of pairing off these skills.
And society, in turn, encourages gender
conformity by making people feel that they have to fit
these molds if they want to be romantically desirable,
and by also teaching people to reject those
who go against these gender norms.
Though this theory was influential in the
mid twentieth century, it’s fallen out of
favor for a few reasons.
First, Parsons was basing his theory on a
division of labor that was specific to middle-class
white America in the 1940s and 50s.
It assumes a heteronormative and Western perspective
on what a family is.
But not all families are nuclear units with
one man, one woman, and a gaggle of children.
When you expand the definition of family to
include same-sex couples, single parents,
multi-generational families, or childless adults,
it’s less obvious that you should assume
that a man works outside the home and
a woman works inside the home.
Second, the idea of complementary genders rests
on there being two distinct and opposite genders.
Again – a Western perspective.
The idea of gender as a binary isn’t universal,
and it ignores all those whose identities don’t
conform to a two-gender system.
Third, Parsons’ theory ignores the personal
and social costs of maintaining rigid gender roles.
Critics argue that the idea that men need
to be the ones working outside the home to
maintain family stability is arbitrary,
and it reinforces gender dynamics that give
men power over women.
Now, another perspective on gender is the
symbolic-interaction approach.
While structural functionalists are concerned
with how gender helps all of society work well,
symbolic-interactionists are more focused
in how gender is part of day to day life.
From this perspective, gender is something
that a person does, rather than something that’s
either innate or imposed by institutions.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble to talk about
different ways that people ‘do gender.’
Clothes, hairstyles, and makeup all telegraph
gender to the people around you.
Take these two people.
You probably have a gut reaction about the gender
of these people, even though the only thing that‘s
different about them is what they’re wearing.
But what if the person in the suit had long
hair or was wearing makeup?
These might flip a switch in our brain to start
seeing the person as a woman in a business suit.
But having short hair and no makeup while wearing
a dress doesn’t necessarily flip the same switch.
This pattern is an example of gender roles,
or how a society defines how women and
men should think and behave.
A man wearing a skirt is seen as more of a
rejection of traditional gender roles than a
woman wearing pants is.
Body language and how people interact with
each other are also part of how people do gender.
Women are socialized to be deferential in
conversation, meaning that they’re more likely to
make eye contact to show that they’re listening,
or to smile as a way of encouraging
their speaking partner.
Crossing your legs is called ‘ladylike’ whereas if
you sit on the subway with your legs spread out,
you might get glared at for ‘manspreading.’
Thanks Thought Bubble.
These exercises in ‘doing gender’ are good examples of how our society’s definitions of masculinity and femininity are inextricably linked to each gender’s power in society.
Masculine traits are associated with power
– taking up more space, directing the conversation
– and are often valued more than feminine traits.
In other words, everyday social interaction
reflects and helps reinforce gender stratification.
But a limitation of the symbolic interaction
approach is that it focuses on the micro,
rather than the macro.
Because of its focus on situational experiences,
it misses the broader patterns of gender inequality.
For that, we need social conflict theory.
You might remember gender conflict theory
from our episode about Harriet Martineau.
But in case you’ve forgotten, gender conflict theory
argues that gender is a structural system that distributes
power and privilege to some and disadvantage to others.
Specifically, that structural system is the patriarchy,
a form of social organization in which men have
more power and dominate other genders.
We can see examples of this structure in
institutional practices that disadvantage women,
like restricting higher education to men or
refusing to allow women to vote.
But we also see this in less official ways.
Think about the traits that our society values
– rationality is often praised as a desirable
way of thinking, especially in leaders,
while irrationality means letting emotion affect
decisions and is seen as a weakness.
Women are stereotyped as more emotional and
men as more rational, which makes people falsely see
men as more natural fits for leadership positions.
The way that patriarchy privileges certain
people over others also isn’t as simple as saying that
all men are at the top of the power distribution.
This is why there’s more attention paid
in sociology to intersectionality,
or the analysis of the interplay of race, class,
gender, sexual orientation and other identities,
which often results in multiple dimensions
of disadvantage.
While all women are disadvantaged by gender,
it’s also true that some women experience more
disadvantage than others.
And the converse is true for men – all men benefit
from living in a society that privileges masculinity,
but some men benefit more than others.
To see this in action, let’s go back to
the stats on the gender wage gap we talked
about in the last episode.
White women make 80 cents for every dollar
a white man makes.
Black women make 65 cents for every dollar
If we divide those two numbers, we get the
wage gap between white women and black women:
a black woman makes 81 cents for every dollar
that a white woman makes.
But what about black men?
Well, they make 73 cents for every dollar that
white men make.
So black women do worse economically than
black men, who do worse than white women,
who do worse than white men.
Just looking at gender or just looking at
race misses the way that disadvantages can
stack on top of one another.
Our understanding of social conflict theory also would
not be complete without discussing a movement closely
entwined with gender conflict theory: feminism.
Feminism is the support of social equality for
all genders, in opposition to patriarchy and sexism.
Broadly speaking, feminism advocates the
elimination of gender stratification,
expanding the choices that women, men and other
genders are allowed to make, ending gender-based
violence, and promoting sexual freedom.
There are many forms that feminism can take,
but let’s highlight three major schools of thought
within feminist theory.
The first is liberal feminism – and no,
I don’t mean liberal in the political sense.
I mean liberal in the classical sense, rooted in the
ideals of freedom of choice and equal opportunity.
Liberal feminists seek to expand the rights
and opportunities of women by removing cultural
and legal barriers to women’s equality,
like implementing policies that prevent discrimination
in the workforce or improve reproductive freedom.
This contrasts with socialist feminism,
which views capitalism as the foundation of
the patriarchy and advocates for full economic
equality in the socialist tradition.
Socialist feminists tend to believe that the
liberal feminist reforms don’t go far enough
since they maintain most of the existing institutions
of power.
The third feminist school of thought is
known as radical feminism,
which believes that to reach gender equality,
society must actually eliminate gender as we know it.
Radical feminism has clashed heavily with
other subsets of feminism, particularly on
transgender individuals’ rights.
Many radical feminists refuse to acknowledge
the gender identities of trans women
and have accused the transgender movement
of perpetuating patriarchal gender norms.
And these three ways of thinking about
feminism are only a few of the many views on
how to best advocate for gender equality.
Kinda like how there are many theories within
sociology about how we should think about gender.
Today, we learned about three of those schools
of thought on gender theory.
Structural functionalism sees gender as a
way of organizing society
and emphasizes the ways that men and women
can act as complements to each other.
Symbolic interactionism looks at gender on
the micro level, exploring how gender guides
day to day life.
And gender conflict theory, intersectional theory,
and the theories of feminism focus on the ways
that gender distributes power within society.
Crash Course Sociology is filmed in the Dr.
Cheryl C. Kinney Studio in Missoula, MT, and
it’s made with the help of all of these
nice people.
Our animation team is Thought Cafe and Crash
Course is made with Adobe Creative Cloud.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for
everyone, forever, you can support the series
at Patreon, a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued support.